Salut ! Quatrième jour ensemble, quatrième jour sur le Rubik's Cube. On touche le bout les amis.
Vous allez bientôt savoir faire le Rubik's Cube, entièrement, en 5 formules, en moins de 2 minutes.
Hier on s'est quittés là-dessus.
Le premier jour vous avez appris à faire la première face, le deuxième jour la première couronne, le troisième jour vous avez appris à faire la croix sur le dessus.
On est presque au bout, il en reste 8 à placer, et aujourd'hui on va apprendre à en placer 4 d'un coup.
En l'occurrence la croix elle est ok. Ce qui n'est pas bon par contre, ce sont les correspondances avec la deuxième couronne.
Ca c'est pas bon.
Et même si on continue à tourner comme ça, ce ne serait jamais bon de tous les cotés.
Il nous faut donc une nouvelle formule pour ça, est ça tombe bien, car je l'ai évidemment.
Et cette formule là, elle est très intéressante parce qu'elle va vous servir également à la dernière étape, c'est une formule qui va vous servir deux fois.
Elle va nous permettre de faire un saute mouton entre les cubes. Je passe derrière la caméra pour mieux vous expliquer.
L'idée est la suivante: on va faire un saute mouton avec les faces des cubes, mais un d'entre eux va rester fixe.
Le orange est bien positionné par rapport à la deuxième couronne.
Le vert va faire un saute mouton jusque là, à sa position.
Le rouge va lui aussi se décaler ici, à sa position.
Et le bleu va se décaler là, à sa position.
Celui-ci restera toujours fixe.
Quand on tient le Rubik's Cube devant soi, ce cube là restera fixe.
Donc on fait passer celui-ci en face,
lui, juste à sa droite,
et lui, juste à sa droite également.
La formule c'est:
Droite Haut, Droite inversé, Haut, Droite Haut Haut, Droite inversé, Haut Haut.
Alors dit comme ça, ce n'est pas évident à retenir. Au lieu de dire  "Haut Haut" je pense à H², moi dans ma tête.
Et si je simplifie encore cette formule dans ma tête, ça donne:
Droite Haute, Droite inversé, Haut, Droite H², Droite inversé, H².
Cette formule là est très simple à se mettre dans les doigts, je vous fais voir:
Donc j'ai positionné une couleur face à la deuxième couronne, je me mets en face, et c'est parti:
Droite
Haut
Droite inversé
Droite
Haut carré (H²)
Droite inversé
Haut carré (H²).
Et on vérifie. Le bleu est bien en face de la deuxième couronne, idem pour le orange, idem pour le vert, idem pour le rouge.
On a protégé les deux couronnes,
on a protégé cette face,
et on a protégé notre croix.
Tout ça, ça n'a pas bougé.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passerait si on s'était trompé au départ ?
Et bien je vais vous faire voir, je vais donc annuler ce que je viens de faire.
Donc pour annuler, je fais ça...
Voilà.
Là je viens d'annuler ce qu'on vient de faire.
Si au départ j'avais mis en place le vert...
Dans ces cas là, le bleu va passer sur le rouge,
le orange au bleu,
et le rouge au orange.
Donc on regarde ce qu'il se passe.
Donc il s'est passé un décalage mais pas le bon.
C'est pas très grave. Si je le réapplique une deuxième fois, ça va placer le bon décalage.
Droite
Haut
Droite inversé
Droite
Haut au carré
Droite inversé
Haut au carré.
En clair ne vous inquiétez pas si votre positionnement de départ n'était pas bon. Si vous ne le teniez pas dans le bon sens, dans ces cas là ne bougez pas
réappliquez la formule, une fois, deux fois, autant de fois que nécessaire.
Mais obligatoirement, avec ce décalage et ce saute mouton,
vous allez à un moment donné, tomber sur la bonne position. Il y a pas le choix, c'est comme ça, c'est mathématique.
Et si on regarde bien, comme promis, vous en avez quatre de plus de bien positionnés. Donc il n'y en a plus que quatre à mettre en place: les 4 angles.
Un fois qu'on aura mis ces quatre là en place, on aura terminé ce Rubik's Cube !
On s'arrête là pour aujourd'hui. Entrainez-vous bien sur cette formule, car elle va nous servir, pas pour la prochaine vidéo, mais dans celle d'après.
Et essayez, au lieu de l'apprendre par cœur, de bien l'assimiler dans les doigts.
Oui, elle n'est pas désagréable à faire, c'est une formule agréable à appliquer.
Faites un focus sur cette formule, jusqu'à demain vous ne vous entrainez qu'à ça.
Oubliez tout le reste pour le moment. Entrainez-vous à cette formule, cette formule, cette formule.
Alors bon entrainement !
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !